when i imagine something i imagine
everyone that i know and love
being a part of it i want to make stuff
that i can see
on the people that i know and they come
in all different shapes
sizes races religions uh
yeah and she wasn't kidding because
rihanna's 2020 savage by
fenty fashion show was stacked to the
max with some major star power
beautiful thing about rihanna is that
she's a global artist and she includes
everyone
yep like real housewives of beverly
hills star erica jane
oh it's the best are you kidding the
best who damn near set the place on fire
from all that heat to be 49 and in a
lingerie
so i mean i just feel
so excited and honored today
and no no your eyes aren't playing
tricks on you
after i got past my shock at even being
asked to be part of this i was thrilled
that's demi freaking more proving age
ain't nothing but a number dripping in
diamonds and rocking a pair of fishnets
yes i'm really excited and on the other
side of the couch
bella hadid slaying in some sexy black
lingerie
surrounded by dancers while she serves
up some serious hadid hotness
i'm just really happy but she wasn't the
only supermodel to work it on riri's
catwalk
arena shake proves she's one hot mama
this is more than a show it's it's a
masterpiece while cara de levine
strutted her stuff
in a thong and sported a blonde mullet
i should be honest i'm just i'm blown
away of course
riri wouldn't be riri without a little
music
[Music]
bad bunny took the mic so did rosalia
travis scott and young thug close down
the show
while lma performed with dj mustard and
roddy rich then there was a sultry
performance from miguel
who shared a little screen time with his
wife nazaneen
[Music]
mandy
[Music]
and while normani didn't sing being a
part of the show it just
i feel like i'm embracing my sexuality
in a different way than i've ever been
able to before
she gave off some major sultry bride
vibes
[Music]
and big sean he didn't perform either
but he did flex that six-pack ab
situation
i'm feeling good as hell
but it was lizzo who really brought down
the house without singing
a single note
india more paris hilton rico nasty
chica and willow smith did some
major posing it's such an honor to be a
part
of this because i feel like rihanna has
become
such an icon a confident woman
no matter what size color shape
your attitude is what makes you savage
yeah
it's the confidence that you have in
yourself but it was the stars of drag
race
who really worked it so
crazy so full circle it is so bizarre to
have a dream come
true that's gigi good jada essence hall
and shay coulee showing us all how it's
done
i hope this audience feels so sexy and
empowered i know just being a part of
the show seeing
all of the different aspects and layers
that have come together it has been just
so
inspirational for me as a person being a
part of it so i can
only imagine how inspirational and
encouraging it will be
to everybody out there watching all
these different representations of
people here in the show tonight
oh and that that's christian combs
posing with
a lot more subtlety and looking a whole
lot like his famous dad
sean combs it's an honor to be here i
can't wait to work with rihanna again
and i think riri can safely drop the mic
you